welcome i fall i send the director of
the center for our society professor of
anthropology and history in the
department of history and i will begin
with few things first of all of course
thank you to my panna visiting this
professor of American history and
culture and emeritus at Quail his talk
today will be on the topic of what
happens when our provokes American
society and why go to a full
introduction to Professor cannon I want
to thank our co-sponsors the university
lecture series and the Department of
History I've actually been charged
excuse me by jaron I earrings a few i
gave this gift on behalf of university
lecture series so now officially and
also i want to thank the department of
history for also co-sponsoring events
and of course to thank all of you for
attending this event in such a busy time
of year for all of us to move on to our
speaker michael chemin as i said a
professor of American history culture at
Cornell had taught at Cornell or by my
count about 45 years and is still
teaching at Cornell effectively so
typically when one each piece of
speakers one does so by referring to
works and prizes these they will the
person publish this book in that book
prizes the problem with because their
cannon is that i did a search on amazon
is okay i was a suitable time then I got
129 kiss on his name I was like okay the
rest came up several Michael Kamen's you
know and of course they're all him and
they're always been and so it's
impossible a kappa number books i went
back to a CD in checked and i counted in
29 books 20 of them single offer so to
quote an essay from an essay in one of
my comic book the book was called in the
past blame the writing of history
hammond notes has often come from the
combined circumstances of confinement
patients and compulsive affections of
historians vocation while we wrote this
to refer to important figures like Sir
Walter Raleigh and Napoleon who wrote
history when under arrest in this case
it's actually not entirely in a couple
because it seems like he'd been able to
do a list even in the absence of a
period of extended confinement or jail
time I think to my knowledge but I think
that he must have that much more
patience and compulsive affection for
history to actually have allowed for
this extraordinary career extraordinary
series of works so I'm not going to try
to even list those out much less
actually comment on all those works I'm
not going to try to list out all these
words and prizes so what I want to do is
offer more of a cartographic survey in
the sense the terrain is all of the work
and warts and and I always try to
mention a few of the rubrics that might
help to orient one if you decided sure
to traverse this landscape I'll know the
very few selected books and prizes as
kind of landmarks terrain that is
imposing
expensive from his earliest work it's
early published work very well known in
colonial American history work like
people with paradox and inquiry
concerning the origins of American
civilization this is a study of the
dynamic interaction of imported and
indigenous elements in American culture
with some ideas and institutions
transferred virtually attack from
Britain while others were transformed in
the New World and I quote from the back
covers where I got this puritanical and
hedonistic idealistic and materialistic
peace-loving and warmongering these
opposing strands about the genesis of
our history in this book 120 surprise
for history in 1973 i believe so from
colonial American history a number of
works that could be classf in American
political history including a machine
that would go of itself a constitution
in American culture this in 1986 which
was described as a huge area diet
exhilarating survey of 200 years of
American sentiments about the 1780s in
the Constitution are brilliantly
intelligent alert and entertaining
Treasury American political legal
culture this book one the Francis
department price and Henry Adams prize
now host of works in American cultural
history I'll just mentioned
three of them I believe or four mystic
chords of memory transformation of
tradition in American culture this is a
mammoth work of research and synthesis
which explored the nexus between
collective memory and national identity
in the United States and according to
one reviewer a truly magisterial survey
of how Americans have engaged the past
from literature painting architecture
pull or antique collecting and the
creation and maintenance of tourist
sites and historical restoration of all
kinds yet another work that's very
well-known American culture American
tastes social change in the 20th century
that's a 1999 study of changing tastes
pieces of leisure and shifting
perceptions of leisure throughout the
United States history and notably
exploring and criticizing understandings
of the relationship during high low and
middle part and physically English
between mass culture and the
commercialization of organized
entertainment right now doesn't focus
ribs I guess it already released or
looked next week or two it's a digging
up the dead history of notable American
be burials an exploration of reburial as
a figurative forward reservation
resurrection of reputation the Sun
taking from the obviously from the book
description as it has not been reviewed
yet reburial can also symbolize
reconciliation with our familiar or
national cabinets floors of politics
mythology and commercialization of the
American practice of burial we had a
very
fascinating discussion over over dinner
last night in which professor can be
displayed his very edition on
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania reserves
that if like tell us about 20 of member
so in sequence now you may ask where is
the place of the arts and all this and
the answer is that is woven throughout
his work warp and woof his histories for
instance mystic chords of memory as I
mentioned for American culture American
tastes and it's especially present and
for granted in his recent 2007 book
visual shock a history of art
controversies in American culture this
is the work that that is that sort of in
a sense for a lot of us were involved in
the center of the arts of society and
particularly in a project of the center
supporting on controversy in the Earth's
really we've been working through this
word we talked about in regular times
and it was what has motivated us to calm
here today hope that that's a that i'm
not going to summarize because i think
your talk today with an abundant sense
of the project and what it's about so
without further ado I will simply see in
place Michael panel thanks very much
thank you in 1987 justice Brennan there
was a conference held at the Supreme
Court to celebrate the actually 1989 to
celebrate the 200th anniversary of the
creation of the federal court system and
justice Brennan spoke after dinner and
he received a a similarly gracious
excessively gracious introduction and
justice Brennan said I'm sorry that my
parents are no longer alive my father
would have enjoyed it and my mother
would have believed it is there anyone
here besides Elena who does not know
lady gaga sure no one Elena do you know
lady gaga well there was there was a
lady gaga 100 years ago who was better
than Lady gaga her name was Eva Tanguay
she was a vaudeville performer she she
sang she danced she did extraordinary
things that for lack of a better rubric
i will call gymnastics she would skip
across the stage she would do
somersaults she would bounce on her butt
all the way across the stage she would
crawl across the stage and she performed
in Pittsburgh and I think 1915 and when
she was introduced she got up and said I
am so glad to be back in Pittsburgh
afterwards someone asked her when was
the last time you were in Pittsburgh she
said I've never been here before so
unlike Eva Tanguay i have been to
pittsburgh before but the last time was
about 28 years ago if anyone is
interested in ava tangle a documentary
has just been made about her or anyone
in popular culture and i can give you
the story of the documentary and a
little bit about her life among
Pittsburgh people I admire I think
august wilson has to be at the top of
the list in the 1970s i I don't live
very far from Cooperstown and the
Baseball Hall of Fame and I watched when
the hall of fame induction takes place
in late July early August there's always
a to professional teams come and play a
game a real game at Doubleday Field in
Cooperstown and i remember in i think it
was nineteen nineteen seventy five I saw
the Pirates play and remember watching
Willie Stargell hit two out of the park
and then I have other memories as you do
some of you do bill Mazeroski and others
i have a new Pittsburgh favorite this
does the name Kyle beltron resonate with
anybody here only only one last week I
was in Houston Texas and watched a
production a very very extraordinary
production of a musical titled in the
heights and the star of the show the
lead in the show as well as the star
though there are other stars but the
most important star was Kyle Beltran BFA
Carnegie Mellon 2009 playing the role of
snobby I assume most of you then don't
know about this musical who snobby
stairs hooker US Navy when loose navi
was born there was a u.s. naval
vegetable vessel that was visible from
where the mother was giving birth so
hence he was named Lou snobby ok
many of the greatest artists have been
provocative and a fair number of them
have sought to be money Brock Picasso
when the year Brock died 1947 a very big
retrospective was mounted in Paris which
then came to New York after number of
months and on the on the cover of the
catalogue were was a quotation from
Brock art is meant to disturb and I
think that that sentiment which he
articulated about as succinctly as any
artist ever has was shared has been
shared by many others and I want to give
you just a couple of examples Roy Larry
rivers was asked to comment on what he
was doing in Washington Crossing the
Delaware and he remarked this was early
in his career he remarked I was
energetic and egomaniacal and what's
more important cocky and angry enough to
want to do something no one in New Year
in the New York art world would doubt
was disgusting dead and absurd Roy
Lichtenstein the pop artist was
reflecting I think in the 1980s on the
emergent pop art scene in the 1960s and
he remarked that the problem for a
hopeful scene making artists in the
early 60s was how best to be
disagreeable what he needed was to find
a body of subject matter sufficiently
odious to offend even lovers of art and
so Lucas time in his case opted for the
vulgarity of comic book images one more
example the sculptor artist George
Sugarman designed but we're called
Baltimore federal as a as a public art
project for a courthouse in Baltimore
the reception was very hostile because
it's a very elongated thing and
district court judges predicted the
dissidents and terrorists would perhaps
use it as a site to harangue mobs and as
a hiding place for for terrorists to
place bombs and Sugarman responded isn't
controversy part of modern art is all
about several American presidents have
made interesting and apropos remarks
when the Museum of Modern Art was
dedicated in or move to a new facility
in 1939 Franklin Delano Roosevelt was
there and he had this to say only when
men are free can the arts flourish and
the civilization of national culture
reached full flower the arts cannot
thrive except where men are free to be
themselves and to be in charge of the
discipline of their own energies and
arturs the conditions for democracy and
for art are one in the same MoMA
celebrated its 25th anniversary in 1954
and Dwight Eisenhower was there on that
occasion and he remarked that artistic
expression serves many of the same
values central to a Democratic Society
and underlying the First Amendment as
does scholarly expression in other
fields in other fields the right of
artists to challenge conventional wisdom
and values is a cornerstone of artistic
and academic freedom we say a little bit
about what was happening in the
post-world War two ERA especially 50s
early 60s that provide a context for
what I want to talk about in terms of
episodes anecdotes images and so on
first of all after world war two the
number of art schools proliferated in
the United States consequently the
number of emerging young artists
proliferated and they needed to
differentiate themselves if they were
going to sell their work and if they
were going to find jobs one way to do
that was to be
provocative so that's part of the the
context one needs to understand what
what happened especially in the later
50s and on into the 60s after world war
two the number of art journals and art
critics proliferating and hence to get
their attention when you're part of this
hugely emergent group one needed to do
startling things third then the there
was a proliferation of different and
fresh forms of art that emerged video
art photography taken seriously as a
fine art which really John SAR Kowski at
the Museum of Modern Art worked very
hard at this only gradually in the 70s
and especially in the 80s did major
museums begin to take photography
seriously performance art installation
art pop art op art minimalism all
emerged in in the early 60s then art off
the easel and sculpture off the pedestal
would begin to emerge and provide part
of the background for for things that we
will be looking at and then government
support for the Arts really emerges in a
major way in 1965 with the creation of
the National Endowment for the Arts and
then perhaps less well-known the
government services administration
creates a program in the 60s that
provides a formula that changed over
time but begins with the the notion that
of one percent for art namely when a
federal structure is is funded and
created and erected there one percent of
the budget for such projects projects
should be set aside so that an artist
can create either a mural inside or a
work of sculpture outside and so forth
many of those projects would become
extremely controversial so much so that
in the later 60s and early 70s the
program was shut down while they tried
to figure out some way to avoid
controversies will will will revisit
that then there's an interesting paradox
that is the last piece of a very complex
story that we need to keep in mind
namely that in the 60s especially the
late 60s and early 70s artists many
artists were in rebellion against
museums they felt that museums were
excessively controlling of artists that
they were not sufficiently appreciative
that artists were not only under under
funded but museums were manipulative in
terms of which works by a given artists
they would display so there is this
rebellion among the artistic community
that surges on into the 70s and and in
many instances continues to this day but
at the same time museum attendance
spikes and continues to spike so that by
the later 1990s museum attendance in the
art museum attendance in the United
States proportional to population was
higher than anywhere else in the world
that begins in about nineteen
ninety-seven then just one last related
point half there are now an
extraordinary number of museums in the
United States when really can't count
them because there's a new one almost
every day half of all the museums in the
United States came into being since 1969
so keep that in mind now let's turn to a
a sequence of sort of historical case
studies I'll try to deal with five and
get you out of here by 10 or 11 o'clock
I'm going to touch on nudity indecency
modernism the transformation of the
American Museum public sculpture
feminism and art so let's start with
with Matisse's blue nude of biskra
which was displayed the painting was
made in in nineteen six was displayed at
the Armory Show the famous or infamous
Armory Show in New York City which then
went to Chicago and Boston in the spring
and summer of nineteen thirteen and it
was considered very shocking when it
when the exhibition got to chicago the
the students at the school of the Art
Institute rebelled and they they tried
matisse in absentia they called him
Henry hair mattress instead of calling
him Matisse they hanged him in effigy
and carried on quite a bit so there's
there's that episode then oh just a
sidebar this is a Matisse work that that
never ceases to amuse me because it it
was given to the Museum of Modern Art in
1954 and moma curators hung it
upside-down not realizing that the the
rudder of the sailboat needs to be on
top and the reflection should be in the
water but they had it flipped and it
took four months before anyone realized
that this sailboat was upside down then
a little bit about about sculpture and
the American resistance to abstraction
being stronger in the realm of sculpture
than in the realm of painting the work
is by Constantin Brancusi burden space
in 1926 there brancusi did a number of
versions of this in in marble in brass
and wood there a number still in Paris
that remain in his studio which is just
on the plaza of the Pompidou Center and
in 1926 a friend a very distinguished
American photographer decided to
bring one into the United States and
when they got a burden space to customs
and it was examined the customs
inspectors decided that it was not art
they categorized it classified it as
plumbing supplies and placed a very
heavy tariff on it so a court case and
litigation followed for two years and
ultimately in 1928 a very enlightened
tribunal of three judges passed down a
decision that essentially read to
paraphrase it succinctly well over the
centuries definitions of art have
changed from time to time and perhaps
the definition the meaning of art is
changing again in our own time and
therefore they reclassified it from
Plumbing Supplies to art which
considerably reduced the tariff that had
to be paid in right after World War two
the State Department the Cold War was
heating up the State Department decided
to organize a traveling exhibition of
American Art mainly of the past's were
forty years they wanted it to open at
the Metropolitan Museum of Art in New
York which it did for a month and then
half of it traveled through Central and
South America or was destined to travel
through Central and South America
beginning in Haiti and the other half
would tour Western Europe beginning in
Prague I believe well when it was
displayed at the metropolitan museum of
art a number of observers critics saw it
and they became very very upset because
the stuff didn't look to them like art
Harry Truman had a look at the show and
made his famous remark if that's art
then I'm a Hottentot this image this
painting by Yeshua kuniyoshi
called circus girl resting was part of
that exhibition for which the state
department paid belief forty-seven
thousand dollars for 85 pieces of art
and comments were made such as the
American girl should look like she can
play the piano not lift one or the
American girl should not look like she
plays tackle for the Chicago Bears and
so on so george c marshall the secretary
of state and he became very alarmed that
this was going to be totally
counterproductive the purpose of the
exhibit was to demonstrate to the free
world the freedom that american artists
enjoyed to do their thing and as opposed
to the soviet union where everything was
socialist realism but George Marshall
decided this was just going to blow up
in our faces and so he pulled the
exhibition and it was it did go to Haiti
and Prague but it never went beyond and
came back and all of the 85 pieces were
sold at auction for five thousand
dollars they are now evenly divided
between auburn university and the
university of oklahoma which got them
for a couple of hundred bucks apiece
okay let's talk about museums American
museums Joseph Hirschhorn began putting
together in sort of the middle third of
the 20th century the most extraordinary
private collection of painting a
sculpture international collection of or
most extruded collection of art and
sculpture internationally created and in
1965 the question emerged where is it
going to go because her short was aging
a number of museums such as the National
Gallery the tape I'm sorry the tape in
London were interested museum in Toronto
the
Ontario art gallery and Lady Bird
Johnson began having conversations with
the Secretary of the Smithsonian
Institution who is the director as funny
title of secretary and the secretary
began lobbying Lady Bird Johnson to have
pillow talk with Lyndon Johnson to get
that collection to the Smithsonian so
the pillow talk occurred it worked
Lyndon Johnson became enthusiastic and
sent a bill to Congress when Congress
saw images of the works that would be in
his collection they got many congressmen
got very upset some very distinguished
museum directors the director of the
cleveland museum of art testified that
this was absurd to have the american
collection of Modern Art reflect the
taste of one individual and that
director whose daughter just recently
resigned as the director of the
Philadelphia Museum of Art urged that
part of her shorts collection be
accepted and that it be complemented
with works from other collections so
that wouldn't reflect the taste of a
single single individual well the
Congress fought over this debated over
this eventually the collection got
accepted that was in nineteen in the
late 1960s but then the whole issue of
the museum's design arose and when
Skidmore Owings and Merrill released the
design the critics got hot again and
said it looks like a bloody bagel or a
donut and there was a great hoo-hah
because one of her shorts conditions for
giving many many millions of dollars
worth of art was that Congress fund the
construction of the building and pay for
permanent maintenance so Congress many
congressmen said we don't want to pay
for that then when it opened in I
believe in 1974 it was really very
interesting because initially
any number of architectural critics were
not happy and could not envision how art
could be suitably displayed in such a
structure when when it opened however
many of them ada louise huxtable for
example were impressed when they went
through it and they thought well this is
pretty cool and for a while for about
the next three years the hirshhorn
became the most-visited Art Museum in
the United States exceeding all others
and it has calmed down since then I was
there two weeks ago for a spectacular
exhibition of the works of Josef Albers
and and some other shows it is it is not
nearly as as well visited as it was in
in the 70s and early 80s but they have
made some marvelous additions to the
collections the here we have one of the
earliest examples of GSA government
services administration Commission it's
a Robert Motherwell commission that was
given to him in I think it's 1964 for a
memorial to John F Kennedy when the
federal government decided to erect an
office building in downtown Boston the
one percent for art formula kicked in
and Robert Motherwell perhaps the most
articulate of all the abstract
expressionist many ways motherwell
speaks for the rest of the Abstract
Expressionists educated harvard college
and he's a very fluent writer saw an
interesting work of his this afternoon
at your museum of art so motherwell gets
the commission and this is the mural
that he completed called Newland elegy
when the Boston Globe sent a reporter to
the opening of of the work he he
interviewed some people asking them what
did they think of New England elegy and
people didn't know what to make of it
it's a very immediately recognizable as
a Robert Motherwell work the reporter
wanted to generate some excitement so he
suggested to a woman uh he asked her one
what do you do you see there what do you
think you see she said I haven't a clue
and he said well is it possible that
that's John F Kennedy in the upper right
at the moment when the bullet is hitting
the back of his head and we're seeing
his brains splattering out into the air
and he is 20 minutes away from death and
the woman said oh my god and the
reporter elicited other reactions with
the same proposal so the next day by the
way at that moment in time the boston
globe and the Boston Herald I'm sorry
the reporter was in Boston Herald and at
that moment the Boston Herald and the
globe were in a heated rivalry for
subscriptions and newsstand sales so the
Herald ran a story the next day an omen
OMG story well the globe wasn't about to
be scooped so they pumped up the issue
and for quite a time there was a huge
debate over whether that's Motherwell's
intention or not but clearly any fool
can see that's what's going on that john
f kennedy's brains are being smattered
into the air finally they got denials
from motherwell himself and Motherwell
shows up and it gradually calm down but
that's when the gsa decided we don't
want censorship but from now on we're
going to ask artists who get these
Commission's to provide maquettes and
graphics so that we can sort of screen
and ask them for an explanation so we
can have a sense of what's what's going
up and what's going on this is the
Chicago Picasso that think from 1967
from that was taken Mayor Daley
the father the first mayor daley Richard
Daley was a great admirer of Picasso
it's not what those of us who were
contemporaries of Mayor Daley expected
of him but he was and he pleaded with
Picasso to do a public art subscription
for Chicago Picasso reluctant if he said
no several times he reluctantly agreed
and eventually gave the work to Chicago
free for no charge at all on Chicago
only had to pay for fabrication costs
what when it was unveiled what everybody
wanted to know was what is it and there
was a lot of excitement speculation
people knew that Picasso owned an Afghan
hound so there was speculation that it
was an Afghan how other people looked at
it very hard and said no no no no it's a
baboon it's obviously a baboon they
began asking Picasso insistently so tell
us already what is it and Picasa
wouldn't answer any wouldn't answer and
finally he he got tired of all this so
he said my thumb it's my wife and that's
where it was left it took about it and
this is very typical of many of these
controversies it took about five or six
years but eventually Chicagoans came to
be very fond of it and to this day or at
our in 2010 Chicagoans who are remotely
interested are very proud of it and that
a any a commission the NEA developed in
1969 a new program different in
interesting ways for public art in
public sculpture but different from the
GSA program because nea had a smaller
budget than the gsa
because the GSA constructions they're
quite expensive and one percent was it
was a fair amount of money mea didn't
have that kind of budget but they worked
out a program whereby they would fund
public art if a community would provide
matching funds according to a certain
formula so they decided that the first
artist should be Alexander Calder who
was then because of new fabrication
techniques expanding the scale of his
works and colder gets this commission
from Milwaukee Lowery's a prince
Milwaukee yeah wait no that's not right
it's in Michigan it's in sorry it's in
Grand grant Thank You June Grand Rapids
and the people in Grand Rapids get very
upset they think they're going to be the
laughingstocks of the country and
they're unhappy about that they're
unhappy because this Plaza in Grand
Rapids was destined for something else
in honor of the former senator
Vandenberg who had been chairman of the
Senate Committee on Foreign Relations
and the people of Grand Rapids really
did not want to be laughed at they also
objected because they learned that
Calder was from Connecticut but was a
great Francophile and they didn't
understand if there if there was a work
a very very big work was going to be
forced upon them hoisted upon them it
could at least be by someone from
Michigan or at least someone from the
upper middle west why do we have to have
this new englander who's a Francophile
and actually has his major studio in
france so they're really ticked off
within then cartoons begin to appear in
the newspapers making fun of Calder and
the work and NEA but juror for
who was prominent on the Republican side
in Congress at the time decided that he
sort of found it interesting and that it
might just be a good thing for his
congressional district so he lobbied
with the ailey and Grand Rapids and that
the work came to be accepted it's called
a very playful Calder s quay the title
of it is Legrand vitesse great speed and
within a year the community and Grand
Rapids had been turned around and this
work appeared as a logo not only of this
on the stationary of City Hall but every
garbage and refuse collection truck in
Grand Rapids had this logo on the side
so this is it this is a case where the
the acceptance came faster than usual
for the opposite of that let's turn to
Richard Sara's tilted arc Commission a
GSA Commission in 1979 that he worked on
for two years for the Foley Plaza in
downtown manhattan near the tip of
Manhattan and that's the new federal
office building and Foley Plaza the the
13 the office workers in that building
hated it they found it menacing it's 72
feet long it's 12 feet high and they
found it menacing threatening like
blocking people had been accustomed to
having their lunches out in folded plaza
and they signed a petition to the GSA
pleading that it be removed in 1985
there was a major litigation began it
ended sort of inconclusively the
testimony that the testimonials on
behalf and against tilted arc are
exceedingly interesting and finally in
believeth 1989 the GSA came in the
middle of the
night and had the whole thing removed in
pieces and it's stored in a warehouse a
very similar work i was telling Kathy's
class this morning a very similar work
with a little bit more curve was put up
in Berlin a couple of years after tilted
ark went up and the reaction the
negative reaction was almost as strong
one graffiti began to appear on it
including 450,000 Deutsche marks for
this eventually it was taken down
but not stored in a warehouse it was
removed to a fairly large plaza but
turned on its side and that plaza to
this day remains as a skateboard
skateboarding closets a halfpipe becomes
a kind of halfpipe let's go to
Cincinnati in 1985-86 Cincinnati began
planning for its Bicentennial in 1989
and they commissioned Andrew Lester a
Canadian to to redesign the the whole
riverfront area which had become very
shabby kind of a mess not very safe and
Andrew Lester came up with his beautiful
ingenious design that would that was
very appealing in many ways and he
wanted it to be he wanted it to touch
base with with a number of historically
meaningful aspects of Cincinnati history
so he decided to have the blue columns
representing the ohio river boats and
Mississippi riverboats with their tall
nineteenth-century smokestacks and on
top of the smokestacks are golden crowns
because Cincinnati was known as the
queen city so they are they represent
royalty
and on the top he decided to put flying
pigs and there you get a different
perspective on the flying pigs why
flying pigs because Cincinnati in the
19th century was known as poor couples
it was the pork slaughtering capital of
the United States and the stench and the
flow of blood etc was known to any
cincinnatian well the there is the best
shot I can give you a flying pig
needless to say as you may remember from
what happened when the Mapplethorpe show
came to Cincinnati in 1990 the hit
the fan when the pig design was released
and the Cincinnati ins felt that they
would become laughing stocks once again
like the folks in Grand Rapids and
others and they said why do we have to
have flying pigs we don't want to be
famous for it for slaughtering pork well
the flying pigs remain and Cincinnati
ins have accepted them much more slowly
than the folks in Grand Rapids did the
okay let's turn to feminism in art and
take as our prime example are Judy
Chicago Judy went to art school in Los
Angeles during the 1960's where in many
instances she was the only woman in her
class or one of two or at the most three
and the men gave her a very hard time so
in the 1970s when she's just emerging as
an artist she began envisioning a
project that would incorporate women's
history not just American women's
history but going back to women in
mythology and she envisioned being
Jewish she envisioned a
a a seder which she would call the
dinner party with place settings for
famous women from various eras so there
are 39 place settings there 13 on each
side and then there are ceramic tiles
inside and on every ceramic tile there
is the name of a woman famous for
painting for politics for for a variety
of reasons so to give you some examples
this so the place settings all of this
were involved a great deal of volunteer
work by many women because there's a
great deal of needlework that was
required a great deal of ceramic work
and so forth so this place setting
happens to be for Emily Dickinson the
American poet and you don't need a great
deal of imagination you don't have to be
a fan of Georgia O'Keeffe to recognize
what's being represented then we have
the place setting for Margaret Sanger
the godmother of birth control clinics
in the United States and you don't have
to be terribly imaginative to know
what's going on there and the place
setting for Georgia O'Keeffe is one that
I think Georgia O'Keeffe would have
heartily approved right now there's an
exhibition of Georgia O'Keeffe's work at
the Phillips Gallery in Washington and
there are God knows how many calla
lilies and various other flowers that
are every bit as vaginal as as the place
setting now all these fees 39 or 38
vaginal place settings were
controversial enough but just to to piss
off everybody we have a place setting
for Sojourner Truth the slave who was
eventually freed in 1828 and became a
major crusader for
abolition and and women's rights the
place setting for sojourner truth is not
vaginal or it's not as explicitly
vaginal as the others so um blanking on
the name of the African American writer
for the moment who wrote an essay about
this saying if Judy Chicago thinks that
the anatomy of black women is different
from the anatomy of white women she
doesn't know what's going on so African
American women were really pissed off
about about the whole thing well the
dinner party migrated they went into
storage it was supposed to go from the
San Francisco Museum of Modern Art where
it opened to Vancouver and then to the
memorial art museum in Rochester they
both cancelled because there was such an
uproar in San Francisco so the work was
folded up and put away in storage in I
think thanking 83 or 84 a group of
American women raised funds to have it
reassembled and travel across the United
States and it appeared in a number of
venues but then after that tour ended
there was still no permanent home for it
in 1990 there was serious consideration
of it's going permanently to the newly
created University of the District of
Columbia when Jesse Helms and other
conservative senators learned about that
possibility at a time when Congress
still exerted total control over
everything in Washington they they
blocked it and so it did not get
permanently placed in UDC finally about
six years ago a very wealthy donor
remember the Sackler family provided
money for a special room to be built to
house it at the Brooklyn Museum of Art
and also provided fellowship money to be
given to the Brooklyn Museum of Art to
support young developing women artists
and so that's where the the dinner party
finally ended up briefly I haven't I
haven't spent much time on controversial
art since the late 1980s because so much
of that story is familiar so we have the
piss christ by under serrano which it
how many of you don't know the story of
piss Christ everybody most of you do ok
that's the Arthur Ashe statue may be
less familiar and I had more of a
personal relationship with that so say a
little bit about it Arthur Ashe was the
great African American tennis star won
the US Open several times a number of
other tournaments and Arthur Ashe came
from Richmond Virginia and in the in the
early 1990s a number of folks in
Richmond began to feel that they're
there really ought to be serious public
recognition of Arthur Ashe in the city
by that time there had been white flight
and Richmond was predominantly I think
I'm guessing something like seventy
percent black if not more and so the the
city councilmen were very enthusiastic
but many prominent folks in Richmond
most of them however living in the
suburbs were very opposed to not to
recognizing Arthur Ashe with a statue
just not on monument avenue where you've
got huge equestrian statues to robert e
lee stonewall jackson and jeb stuart so
any
where but Monument Avenue and the City
Council said why not Monument Avenue
he's a man for our time and he's a hell
of a lot more important than robert e
lee and Stonewall Jackson and jeb stuart
so there was a battle royal over whether
or not Arthur Ashe would be placed there
and i was there in early august of 1996
when it was unveiled national TV cameras
were there and it was the big story that
night on CBS Nightly News and NBC and
ABC and so on and it's an what's
wonderful is that he's holding a tennis
racket in his left hand and he's holding
books in his right hand for the
youngsters who are black and white just
a word about about Robert Henry Salome
you've got the museum here you've got a
gorgeous Robert Henry from exactly this
is nineteen nine Salome was the oh the
Opera Salome Strauss's opera had
premiered in Europe a few years before
and early in the 20th century and in
nineteen seven a very very wealthy
jewish banker in New York City put
together the financial package to mount
a production of Salome at the
Metropolitan Opera JPMorgan's daughter
was present for the opening night and
she was appalled at the semi nudity and
at the bloody head and so forth and she
told her father and had the production
stopped it never got beyond opening
night well Robert Henry the leader of
the ashcan school and many many others
were so intrigued by this brouhaha that
there was a rage national rage for
painting Salome's and so this is Henry's
version but there are many men
others that appeared so
are we doing another 10 minutes or
should should we stop who's hungry
Oliver war okay let's I I tried to
abridge all this because I wouldn't
wasn't quite sure how I would take but a
little bit more horatio greenough was
the preeminent American sculptor that
really the first preeminent American
sculptor 18 20s 30s 40s 50s and when in
1832 approached Congress felt the
centennial of the birth of George
Washington is going to occur in 1832 we
need to honor him big time so let's
commission a statue of Washington that
will go and the rotunda of the United
States Capitol so greenough gets the
commission in the late 1820s and his
studio hi Elena how you doing you good
okay you're staying for a while good
that's pulse Paul's daughter was four
which is adorable okay so green oh green
owes studio is in Florence and he works
on this work which is huge it's marble
and the question becomes how are they
going to get it to Washington people
were sure it was going to sink the boat
and but it made it and then they
skeptics doubted whether they could get
it through the front doors of the US
Capitol that it was too large but they
got it in so they get it in and it's in
place exactly where Congress wanted it
to be but greenock came to see how it
looked and he was very disappointed
because there's no electricity and the
lighting was really bad lighting was a
whale or so greenough pleaded
that they put it outside on the east
plaza and there was a great deal of
debate over whether or not to do that
eventually green 01 and it was moved out
to the east plaza where in on a day like
this it was just spectacular but not
only did people like it so did the
pigeons and so it got whitewashed and it
became a cleaning problem and it became
a public health problem so eventually it
would it was moved to the Smithsonian to
the arts and industries building but now
it occupies a place of honor in the
National Museum of American History but
when it emerged on the east plaza but
even before that actually while I was
even still in the Rotunda there were a
lot of people very unhappy with it they
said ah obviously George Washington is
made to look like a Roman senator and
people wanted him looking American and
not Roman and they wanted George
Washington to be as he was and not like
someone he never was and Nathaniel
Hawthorne made a comment that George
Washington was never seated with only a
napkin covering his genitals there were
there were various other comments about
how inappropriate the the choice of
Roman senator with with sandals and bare
toes and so forth okay the link it's
hard for people today to imagine that
the lincoln memorial was ever
controversial could have been
controversial it was it was the result
of a huge debate again for another
Centennial because Lincoln was born in
1809 as 1909 approached Congress decided
that he should be honored in an
appropriate way in the nation's capital
but then the issue on multiple issues
arose first of all what kind of a
memorial and where the decision was
reached or
was proposed the proposal was made that
it should be located it should anchor
the the US Capitol two miles away but at
that time the the area where the lincoln
memorial is was all marsh it was a very
very swampy area that had never been
drained and the Tiber the so-called
tiber river flowed in eventually a canal
would be created to divert that water
and then eventually the canal would be
covered but the Speaker of the House Joe
Cannon who was a great Lincoln fan and
from the Middle West said I'll be God in
a letter to the to the Secretary of War
I'll be goddamned if you they will
dishonor Abraham Lincoln by putting his
memorial in a bloody swamp so there was
a huge debate over that but it was
resolved by draining the swamp leveling
it and so forth there were any number of
other issues that that I won't go into
but the next issue was what form the
memorial should take and when the
decision was made that it in 1912 that
it should be neoclassical there were
critics and skeptics who said Lincoln
didn't know any Greek Lincoln didn't
care a fig about the Greeks let's do
something practical so there were that
Lincoln a very practical utilitarian man
would have approved on so the major
alternative to a neoclassical design was
the idea of a 72 mile high way that
would connect Washington with Gettysburg
Pennsylvania because the gettysburg
address etc that made sense so a bill
was introduced in Congress it was
debated it was narrowly defeated and
eventually the neoclassical design one
out for Bacon's commission but when it
was finally completed World War One
halted progress on the memorial when it
was unveiled
to speak in 1922 Louis Sullivan the
patriarch of American Arctic to
architecture condemned it as being the
death of American architecture young
Frank Lloyd Wright to claim that it was
god-awful any number of other critics
agreed and so on and it's an interesting
span to contemplate span of time to
contemplate from the controversy over
the lincoln memorial to the Vietnam
Veterans Memorial in the early 1980s
which initially which is now the most
beloved memorial in the United States
and the most visited but initially my
lens design was fiercely opposed there
were any number of compromises that had
to be fought through and worked through
such as the statue of the three
servicemen one black one white one
Hispanic and there's a big fight over
how close it would be Ross Perot and
many members of Congress wanted to be
very close those who didn't want it at
all thought to have it not too close and
so on so that whole controversy was
pretty juicy finally Rodan's the kiss in
1893 the World's Columbian Exposition
was held in chicago and the display of
american art they invited 425 works
paintings and sculptures by american
artists and that was the major art
display at the exposition but they
decided the the art committee involved
decided to invite works by a small
handful of distinguished European
artists and they invited Rodin who sent
to works each one of them with with
basically the same motif kissing but
very different works and we will go into
into the differences but this one was
the major work
and when it arrived in chicago the art
committee looked at it and again said
OMG what upset them was not so much that
they were kissing not so much that they
were nude but that the aggressor is a
woman he's kind of passive no hand on
the butt but she's the honey so they
they couldn't stand it and so they
relegated the work to a special side
hall and you needed special admission
you sort of had to be interviewed and
have special permission to get to see it
and so is by very limited very limited
number of people saw it and they sent it
back as soon as they possibly could
almost not quite but almost on the next
ship okay let's stop there and you have
questions comments whatever whatever
yeah John
great example to
is there a common denominator here that
you say we vote that art controversies
has a whole pretty much always start in
the art world and then move out to the
public world yes absolutely would you
hold that because most of these examples
were of that kind of movement fun and
hardware that artists took more or less
out to provoke in some way or may not be
so much but where where can he find a
case where the art world was mine
suppose an artist was trying to vote
necessarily but some outside forces like
they are doing on your pasta
and politically motivated course we
create controversy when the art itself
was brewing that Roman example I saw her
was you're very entertaining motherwell
interpretation of it makes it grow from
this pic floor but are there any others
you can think of like that where the
heart is sort of secondary to the
motives of the social class where the
art was not intended to provoke such a
state I can do agree with what you
already involved in the art
controversies come out of the art world
in some way or about struggle glory in
your pain but I'm just wondering if
there are cases where the fight is being
picked on the outside well in the case
of Mayor Giuliani and sensation
sensation in 1999 at the Brooklyn Museum
of Art really was not intended to
provoke it had other Algeria had
ulterior motives but it was intended to
stimulate but not provoke the Brooklyn
museum's attendance was not very good
they needed people at the turnstiles the
Brooklyn Museum needed to expand they
had a building project the director had
come three years earlier from the
Baltimore Museum of Art and his name is
lehman and he he needed to generate
interest not controversy he did not want
the Brooklyn Museum is owned by the city
of New York pays rent to the city of New
York he did not want or need a fight
with Mayor Rudy Giuliani he wanted he
simply wanted to get people into the
museum and there is some art in the show
by damien hirst by chris ofili as those
two especially the shark and
formaldehyde and christofias black
madonna with elephant shellacked
elephant dung on her breasts and and
pornographic cutouts from hustler and
other men's magazines of woman's
genitalia are sprinkled around the black
madonna which and from a distance from a
normal viewing distance you can't even
see what they are you have to get very
very close to to know what's going on
there the Brooklyn Museum actually sent
images that's the show had first run in
London two years earlier and it did
cause a kind of sensation but for
tote for totally different reasons than
the the reasons that prompted the
sensation in New York it caused a
sensation in London because one of the
images in the show is of a murderer a
mass murderer in England who the public
did not think should be immortalized
with a very contemporary sort of
portrait portrait bust so the ink the
Brits were really upset that that image
had zero impact in the United States it
was just ignored it's not if you didn't
know about this killer it was totally
uninteresting but but the shark and and
there was a head of a man made entirely
out of dried blood plasma with a kind of
not of blood at the top of the skull
that was upsetting but the BMA sent
images of the exhibition to the mayor's
office four months before the show open
saying ok and they never got a response
because no one in the mayor's office
paid any attention to the images they
thought this is what is this this is an
oculus VMA the exhibition the big deal
we we have to look at this but the press
somehow got a hold of these images
someone in the mayor's office made
images available to the press and not
the Hearst Newspapers anyway New York
City tabloids began one month before
sensation opened began running the
images and so before the show ever
opened it was accused and damned so
Lehman got what he wanted in a sense
because the number of people who came
and came again and came again and came
after a while just see who else was
there it became V thing to go to in New
York City
so that's an instance and I think a
pretty unusual instance of the art world
not trying to be iconoclastic but the
other charge that was leveled was that
all of these works are were owned by the
biggest dealer in contemporary art in
London momentarily blanking on his name
probably thought you thank you thank you
very much si double a TCH I the students
have all gone you under great anyway so
such e under stuff and the accusation
was that the prices would escalate the
value of the works would escalate
because of all the hoo-ha and that that
Saatchi there was also the accusation
that Saatchi had actually contributed
forgetting how much $250,000 to the BMA
if they would accept the exhibition and
that I think Christy's had contributed
$25,000 because they had a stake in the
deal etc so it became a cause celebra
for many many different reasons but it's
a pretty unusual example of what you're
asking about could you comment on
governmental co-option are that becomes
controversial because of the proper like
a distraction for exam
which you've written about like I've
stride I reckon an abstraction be used
as a tool abroad by the government in
what would try to think Larry what would
I just wonder is there a particular
piece and coops they form of art for its
own purposes yeah when the art has no
commercial intention and then it becomes
used as a means of confronting another
culture this is what I'm yeah looking at
and particularly cold war stuff which is
what i have seen but durrett if we mean
45 to 65 arm except for the traveling
show the traveling show in 47 that was
designed to travel from 47 to 49 that
had virtually no abstract art in it
obviously I abstract expressionism had
barely emerged in 43 45 Jack Life
magazine didn't hop on didn't decide
that Jackson Pollock was worth a story
until nineteen fifty when it asked as a
rhetorical question is Jackson Pollock
the greatest American artist of the 20th
century so I'm oh thank you okay okay
okay yeah yeah yeahs in 50 in the
mid-50s are not sure how much the
government was actually involved anyway
the olympics were held in I guess Sydney
in 56 it has to be and a number of
American artists were commissioned to do
to do pieces that would be displayed as
work by contemporary american arts been
Sean was one there were sort of half a
dozen
I don't think any of them was abstract I
think they were all representational but
they were certainly very contemporary
and their work was initially displayed
in the Dallas Museum of Art in 54 55 and
what's-his-name hunt the oil tycoon hunt
yeah thank you HL hunt his wife actually
was head of the ladies some ladies group
not the DAR but the sort of the ladies
group in charge of making sure that
there was nice art and the Dallas then
dallas museum of art not the rusher
didn't exist yet and the party yeah well
no that's Chicago that's the women's
decency that's that's 1936 in Chicago
but anyway this group of women with a
lot of support from a congress a
michigan congressman who hated modern
art and above all flowery hated abstract
art so they they tried to condemn the
art in in the Dallas Museum and they
they failed because the director had a
lot of guts and by the way the Congress
the Michigan congressman who was trying
to close down contemporary art all over
the United States he made nine to nine
or eleven nine major addresses to
Congress mrs. before c-span non-major
addresses condemning modern America
modern American art and he insisted and
this is where the McCarthy aspect comes
in he insisted that all this work was
being done by Communists and especially
Jewish communists so the the director of
the Dallas art museum was very gutsy and
uh he he mobilized his trustees I don't
quite know how I still don't understand
how he did it big
to this day the trustees and houston and
dallas and fort worth of the very
wonderful wonderful museums there tend
to be very conservative certainly a
strong majority but he mobilized his
trustees and he would not fold but the
art showing baseball lacrosse hockey was
supposed to go by american artists was
supposed to go to sydney to be displayed
at the the summer olympics in sydney and
they were shut that down they prevented
that art from being sent so um I don't
even I'm not at all sure you may know
more about this than I do I'm not sure
that the US government particularly had
much of an investment in sending that
are yeah yeah
Oh
ask
even though was created by oh
that's because it was true see and
that's cause off from a whole essay
about how it was an instrument this is
the venice biennale you talk about the
venice biennale yes no absolutely in
your thesis I supervise a senior thesis
on this but but this was not US
government well it had US government
sanction but the initiative for that
came from a curator at the Art Institute
of Chicago working with friends at moma
she I'm blanking on her name which is
not terribly important though she's a
very interesting and appealing woman she
was given responsibility you're you're
mostly right she was given
responsibility for curating what would
represent the United States at the
venice biennale i think in 1957 and i
might be off by one year but i think 57
is right the senior thesis was nine
years ago i remember that better than
the date of the Biennale anyway and she
was given a cue that abstract
expressionism would be a good thing
because it would be perceived as
ideologically unmotivated so you get
works like ancient secrets all these
works have have Jungian titles are and
and in fact we now know the abstract
expressionist were not nearly as a
political as they were supposed to have
been but she she negotiated the choice
of which artists and which works with a
buddy a colleague at MoMA and that's how
the selection was made and the US
government said fine and dandy so they
the US government doesn't doesn't choose
what goes but they sort of i think they
provided so usia had been created in
1953 for precisely the purpose of
representing the u.s. in appropriate
ways abroad and so i became the
beneficiary that in in starting in 1975
and began making trips to to Western
Europe and eventually other parts of the
world sent by usia to talk about
American art and so forth but no one at
the State Department or us I a ever
suggested what I should or should not
talk about now by sitting by 75 the Cold
War was still very much a reality and
and I did a number of Fulbright gigs and
Ford usia and for full bright and so the
closest the closest i can think of that
we've come to government having an
ideological investment would be the
venice biennale in 57 but yep yep can I
just a salir that I don't have the exact
date so there was a cold war front
organization called the Congress
repulsion for you know and it was funded
by the sea at least in part by the CIA
and by immediately is that
50s they actually did sponsor exhibits
connected with museum from honor guard
and at promoting abstract expressionist
offensive thing and he was at least in
Paris I don't know where else but I
think it kind of tour Europe I think
part of the idea was that his socialist
realism in the Soviet zone was it was
all representational and you had this
freedom to be abstract to the west I
think you're absolutely right i've
forgotten about that there are two books
about there's a not very good book
written by a woman run the latest
english that appeared Francis O to
Saunders thank you that's exactly right
penny it's neither well written and some
of it is wrong there's an earlier book
by an American that doesn't have as much
anecdotally detail but it's much more
accurate about what went on I'm trying
to you're absolutely right about the CIA
funding but I can't remember where the
art King firm or I don't think the CIA
the what it was called flavor
committee for logistic freedom covers
for cultural priest yeah they also
subsidized the counter magazine number
of in France yeah yeah some jerk like
offices in London major offices abroad
in London yep on me it's looking at
examples of provocative art where people
just didn't like pain for sculpture that
they thought was meaningless but it
really it seems like art like this is
provocative because it addresses anxiety
in the culture or reality in the culture
that movies ready for for instance
mid-story in America that mocked and
African Americans and the history of
african-americans is a wrong history a
shameful history it was completely
acceptable but doing something about
what's our relationship to slavery is a
touchstone in today for me and similarly
what this is the present such a savage
here as Milton yeah I mean this is like
women are sexual would have desired no
no no nobody has designed great I mean
we've been starting with this since the
Victorians right and so today we have
the date the Dutch cartoonists are they
presenting fundamental Muslims as they
are or are they mocking their God you
know Dutchess age that they may start
finish and you know
this is anybody able to publish anything
about Islam the holidays without getting
stone or you know shot or Marburg nobody
knows as we're all scared and I think
that's the primary function of art Jesse
helps as interpretation is I shouldn't
be bothered by it you should make me
feel safe I think that's the real issue
is that it should be funded in the
artists are ahead of the rest of us no
you're right yes so you begin by making
the claim that our artists as a classy
and our function is to cause harm
efficient but way see it's it's it again
you can add a baton claim that are these
an artists are fundaments intending to
produced oculars often not always for
office I mean there's a lovely healthy
landscape